but they didn't tell you this did they
they didn't show you this no I never
knew about this of course
[Music]
not how you doing yeah what's good
what's up what's up you Muslim um yeah
well kind of long story but yeah explain
yourself um basically um I haven't taken
Shada yet but I'm I'm in the process
what's making you think about taking
your shahada well I'm from I'm from the
cariban right mhm specifically like shad
and we like we have our like we have a
really multi Multicultural Society Okay
and like I I I grew up around
Christianity Hinduism
Islam and well I like all three but the
only reason why I kind of agree with
Islam is that well the reason I like
Islam more than the others it's simply
because not specifically the belief but
just what it represents and not I I'm
not talking about like like the the
extremist perspective of it like the um
I don't to explain to you like the the
morals of the morals of it because I
mean there is there is faults in it
there is some faults but I mean
everything has its fault and so wait
you're saying that there are some
falsehoods in Islam but overall it's
good when I say false I mean things that
I don't completely agree with that's
what I mean false like like what what's
what's something that you don't agree
with in Islam I don't like like the fact
that the um the the level of power male
has over female now when you go to the
hadit now you do see that like Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him would have
been he would have treated his first
wife really well but I mean there's
parts of it that I I personally think
it's simply because it was a religion
that was formed what um around 12 um
close to 2000 years ago well a little
bit less but you know I mean what do you
think about his marriage with Aisha I um
well when I when I read about it it
wasn't uh a mar it the it was really it
was to take care of her to make sure
that she wasn't that's not
true I'm I'm not completely sure because
I didn't look too deep into it yet if
that makes sense oh yeah yeah so she she
her her father was Muhammad's best
friend Abu Bakr she was she was in a in
a perfect home where you know husband
and wife are there and she had shelter
she didn't need Muhammad to take care of
her she had her father already taken
care of her so oh yeah but but what do
you what do you think about the age
difference between
her that doesn't that doesn't sit well
with me I am so happy to hear that bro I
am so happy to hear that because uh like
it's it's it's only been in this
religion in my experience that I have
found people defending PDF filia this is
the only religion that does it they'll
openly try to make excuses for it but
I'm glad that you can be honest and say
yeah that that that I can't get with I
appreciate that that's good that's a
good sign so so I guess my question
would be how how then could you consider
Muhammad a good man or even having
morals or a good prophet of God if he's
saying if he you
know got with a little girl how how can
you take your shahada and follow a man
who claims to be a prophet and used God
as an excuse
to um
you know sleep with a little girl and
marry a little
girl well okay I again I don't agree
with with that and what he did um I
haven't even really looked deep into it
um I've heard people mention it but I
don't know like the full story of it I
I'll turn my screen on so that um you
can see all the
sources that talk about this it says
narrated Aisha so this is Aisha saying
it herself
that the prophet married her when she
was six years
old she was six years old when he
married her and he consummated the his
marriage when she was n years old what
does consummated mean it means to have
sex Jesus Christ oh yeah having
consummation of marriage is when you you
finalize the marriage by having sexual
intercourse so yep she was 9 years old
when um Muhammad you know uh uh you know
did did his thing did dingy dingy with
her so that's sahib bukari now you're
new to this so let me just let you know
what this is sahib bukari is their most
authentic book of Hadith and it's the
most authentic book next to the Quran so
obviously you have the Quran number one
sah bukari would be number
two okay um wait sorry to interrupt you
um yeah I see there's a guy in chat he
says that he he like he wanted that to
discuss with you and well as I said I
just joined because I wanted to see your
perspective I think um I'll be I'll be
watching though so whatever you serious
consideration you want to drop yeah I
see there another guy says he like he
because he seems like he's Muslim and
he's able to debate you oh you can stay
too you don't have to drop all right
yeah cool cool cool yeah I don't mind
that so this isn't about well actually
yeah let's um who who is he what's his
name um it's he has a a black flag and
then it's Arabic all right do with the
Black Flag who has an Arabic name come
on up send a request if you if you
believe that you can defend this I would
I would love to see you watch a Muslim
fail to defend this I would love that so
yeah don't go anywhere if Muslim if if
Muslims if you guys think because it
it'll actually it'll actually do me a
favor in showing you that they try to
defend this stuff they try to defend PDF
philia and you know the excuses that
they come up with and I want you to hear
their their best reasoning for this so
that you can see how false and crazy
this is so now obviously we know that
this is disgusting right Adrian yeah
100% now let's keep let's keep going
because there's there's more like this
is just one of them all I'm gonna let
you know right now all of them say the
same thing now what one difference that
you might see is the age she was when
she married him like so this one says
six there may be in like one or two
others that say she was seven when when
they got married but all of them say the
the same thing about when the marriage
was consummated when he had sex with her
was when she was nine they're all they
all say the same thing on that there's
no difference all right so let's let's
just uh just scroll down and see all
right so here's another one say bukari
this one is
5158 same thing uh narrated this time
it's Aura the prophet wrote The M wrote
the marriage contract with Aisha while
she was 6 years old and consummated his
marriage with her while she was N9 years
old yeah and she remained with him for
nine years I.E till his death so he died
when she was 18 so narrated Aisha she's
gonna be speaking in in the first person
the messenger of Allah married me when I
was seven years
old the narrator sulaman said or six
years old right now here it is he had
intercourse with me when I was 9 years
old old he had intercourse with her yeah
that's
crazy now this is the people that people
say that is a prophet that is a prophet
of God who is the most is the best
example for all mankind somebody we
should all follow and listen to this
dude right here is doing this which
causes in a lot of Muslim countries and
Civilizations for men to seek out young
girls when they married this happens to
this day because of Muhammad yeah that's
mod way yeah now let's let me show you
one that actually says that she was uh
playing with her dolls when when he uh
when he consumated when he married her
she still had her dolls with her bro
just so just in case someone says oh
well Aisha was mature when she was six
and she was mature when she was nine
when she was nine she was a woman that's
crazy that's C but but that's what they
say bro that's what they say they say
Aisha was a special case she was mature
when she was 9 years old she was a woman
then right she wasn't a child at 9 let
me show you let she was playing with
dolls bro so this is the one sahim
Muslim 1422 C for guys on YouTube who
can't see
this all right Aisha may Allah be
pleased with her
reported that Allah's Apostle married
her when she was 7 years old and and was
taken to his house as a bride when she
was 9 years old and her dolls were with
her and when he died she was 18 years
old so when Muhammad slept with Aisha
she still was playing with
dolls yeah that's C
that I don't even know what to
say yeah kind of weird now I don't know
huh this is the religion bro that they
were trying to to bring you in but they
didn't tell you this did they they
didn't show you this no I never knew
about this of course not because they
know that if you knew about this this
would drive you away from Islam drive
you away from from Muhammad um and all
that kind of stuff now but but it gets
worse because this isn't this isn't just
it's worse than this want to know
why because this isn't just Muhammad
doing this this is
actually oh of course there's other
people but but there's a reason why
there's other people it's
because it's taught in the
Quran the Quran says that this is okay
let me show you this is the chapter of
divorce okay that's the name of the
chapter
65:4 so it's telling you how to divorce
like what to do when you divorce your
females okay yeah all right so says and
those of your women who have passed the
age of monthly
courses for them the ID the prescrib
period if you have doubts is three
months now let me tell you what the it
is the ID is the waiting period when a
man divorces his wife it's her waiting
period to make sure that she's not
pregnant so that she can go and and move
on to the next man okay yeah so it's to
make sure that she's not pregnant so she
has to wait three months so this is for
ones who are too old to administrate
right they've passed the age of monthly
courses so for them their waiting period
if you have doubts is three months so if
you doubt that she might be pregnant or
not you doubt about her period just wait
three months if if she's not pregnant
she's good to go right then it says and
for those who have no
courses now the commentator The Scholar
puts in I.E they are still
immature so these are yeah these are
girls who have not menrad yet so these
are the first category are women who
have passed the age of ministration
right that's
menopause then the second category those
who have no courses those are girls who
haven't minated at all they haven't
minated yet they're still
immature okay it says their ID is three
months likewise so they also have to
wait three months
now remember the ID is to see if the
girl is pregnant or not
so the only way to get pregnant Adrien
in a marriage is is what what happens
you you know what happens
right yeah I'm seeing it now yes the
only way to get pregnant is if you you
know y'all sleep together yeah right so
that's who has an ID so there's no point
of an Ida if you haven't slept with the
girl because you got nothing to worry
about no doubts to have so the fact that
these girls who haven't even been stated
yet they're still
immature the fact that they have a
waiting period means that their husbands
slept with them because they need to
make sure they're not
pregnant this is in the Quran let me
just show you another layer of this
because you you have a lot of people
saying oh he's lying he's lying he's
making this up ask a question and people
like defend it like people defend this
yes yes yes yes all the time bro I I
have discussions with people with
Muslims and you have people that
literally make every excuse in the world
they'll try to say for example
um uh you know if God said it then it's
okay they'll say if God said it then
then Subhan Allah you know Allah abbar
he said it it's okay that's one that's
one excuse is there anybody El I want I
want to see that up I actually want to
see that upward yeah let's let's see
let's see a Muslim come up and defend
this what's going on peace and blessings
brother to be back peace and blessings
peace and blessings and what and what
are your thoughts on uh him with his
marriage with Aisha when he six years
old and then consuma at nine with the
marriage right uh I think we really got
to look at the society and the times
this happen Society
[Music]
okay but it was a time where that was AC
accepted and that was okay there there
there was a there was a time where
slavery was accepted
too okay did that make it okay just
because it was accepted in that
time in that time it was the norm it was
the social Norm black people had does
that make it okay you hear you just said
that was
normal okay so I said slavery at the
time of slavery it was a social Norm
even black wealthy people had
slaves if we want to talk about the
transatlantic slave trade I'm not saying
I'm not saying that's that is it is okay
but at that time it was acceptable so
his best friend Abu bucker peace be upon
Him gave his daughter to him which at
that time that was something honorable
just like if you have he's the prophet
is he going to say no to the
prophet say that again is he going to
say no to the prophet that's the prophet
is he gonna say no to M he offered
didn't ask no he no he did not no he did
ask okay show show me where what are you
talking about tell me okay yeah I'll
show you that in a second so slavery
being accepted because we're gonna go
one step at a time slavery being
accepted an acceptable practice back
then does that make it okay right today
no no no I'm not asking today I'm asking
period does it make it okay and by the
way I did not I did not drop him guys my
I'm literally holding the cam the camera
to the computer my my hands are on the
on the mouse and and holding the the
phone I did not drop him he he left for
some reason so Adrian you see though I
told you yeah I know I was even worse
cuz he said slavery was all right then
he brought up he brought up he what's up
slavery
um okay I I'm not completely like
informed with or cuz I'm so like there's
so many things in religion and like I'm
I hav I don't know everything but I'm
also a history student so like I know
the history really well and what he was
what he was talking about when he said
slavery and black people own black
people it was not it was no way as bad
as what happened in the Caribbean what
happened in the Americas I don't know
know someone that's that I don't know
man to just to use that as a
justification makes it 10 times worse
yeah
what is what I don't I don't see him
back here let maybe maybe we can try
another one only Muslims hello how you
doing you hear me yeah you speak English
yes oh you see now that you see how it
is that's a Muslim who just cursed us
out Cur the smooth Out
Boy and it's all because Adrien we're
just reading their sources this is what
happens I kid you not I'm not
exaggerating if you watch my stuff this
happens all the time notice did I say
anything disrespectful or am I mocking
in any way or are we just reading what
their text says
Adrian you're just reading we just
reading over here man we we literally
have a saying we're going to put on a
t-shirt
we say we just read man we just read
here we just going to read and they get
so upset when we just read they
manifest because they know that this is
wrong they know that they can't defend
it and they know when normal people hear
this stuff they they cringe it it turns
them away from Islam and they don't want
us talking about this they tell you they
tell you this fluff about Islam when
nothing of what they're saying is true
when you actually deal with Islam you
actually get into it you see stuff like
this when you actually read what the
Quran says you you get stuff like this
in 654 child huh people read this people
read this on their normal with it I
think this is what I think bro because
uh honestly a lot of the Muslims that I
talk to are ignorant about what the
Quran says so a lot of them they they
grow up in it and you know they don't
know that this stuff is in here um and
then they're but they're so ingratiated
into the religion already that they'll
make excuses you know they'll
say yeah there there's yeah so it's
already like it's it's a wrap like it's
it's tough breaking through you know
they'll say oh well you know the
prophets he's he's obeying Allah and you
know Zade divorced her so this is okay
and they'll make excuses um so it's
tough or even with even with converts
like you was you was about to be a
Muslim convert so like if you got into
it enough you would would have already
been emotionally invested in it and so
even showing you this stuff would not
have phased you you would have been like
you you know probably would have just
like them no no no I can't no I'm being
honest I'm being honest it doesn't
matter how long I do something if if I
any if I see that no no no no that's
sick I'm not I can never support that
yeah that's good to hear
brother so this is this is only a few
things though bro like if you watch like
I'm not the only one but if you if you
you follow me bro you watch my stuff
watch my YouTube there's a bunch of this
type of stuff we go through the Quran we
go we go through the Hadith we show it
on the screen we give the links so that
you guys can have it yourselves we
literally show you what Islam really
[Music]
is oh